[Música]
ya lo decíamos en directo Vamos hasta la
capital mexicana porque hay críticas al
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
que en sus declaraciones redujo el
impacto que tuvieron las protestas en
las que participaron miles de mexicanos
para reprobar la propuesta de reforma al
Instituto Nacional electoral y a varios
artículos de la constitución que impulsa
el gobierno conectamos con Mario carbón
él les corresponsal de France 24 en
Ciudad de México Mario cómo estuvo la
participación ciudadana ayer en estas
marchas
Hola pues fue copiosa fue copiosa la
participación como hacía rato no se veía
hubo perfiles de diversa índole
ciertamente hubo pues varias señoras
señores familias enteras también
acudieron líderes de partidos políticos
de oposición y una que otro personaje
que el presidente descalificó por haber
estado involucrado en pasadas elecciones
en algunos cuestionamientos sin embargo
bueno el presidente
descalificó como lo había venido
haciendo los días previos a la marcha
descalificó esta movilización dijo que
Quienes se manifestaron Más allá de ir
en contra de la propuesta de reforma
electoral en realidad estaban en contra
de la transformación que él está
encabezando y defendían los privilegios
de una élite del poder que aún estaba
enquistada en el país los ciudadanos sin
embargo bueno gritaron consignas como yo
defiendo al Instituto Nacional electoral
el INE y el
ante la propuesta del presidente de
transformar esa institución que se
encarga de organizar los comicios de
organizar las elecciones en el país el
presidente dijo que no había sido mucha
gente a pesar de que los vídeos
claramente podían mostrarse apreciaba
pues decenas de miles de personas bueno
y cuáles son los detalles de la Reforma
que propuso López Obrador porque los
críticos la califican de regresiva
lo que plantea son bueno entre otras
cosas la reducción del Congreso pasar de
500 diputados a sólo 300 pasar de 128
senadores a sólo 96 reducir el
financiamiento de los partidos políticos
y que la elección de los consejeros
electorales y los magistrados del
tribunal electoral sea directa por vía
del voto popular desaparece también los
consejos electorales locales los
críticos lo que señalan es que en
realidad lo que se pretende es
desmantelar la autonomía del instituto
al centralizar las elecciones y que si
bien plantea que se vote directamente a
los consejeros electorales y los
magistrados esto es a partir de una
propuesta de candidatos que el propio
gobierno presentaría así como el
congreso con mayoría a fin al partido en
el poder y la corte con mayoría de
ministros también simpatizantes o afines
a lo que él llama la cuarta
transformación así las posturas
encontradas de quienes están a favor de
esta propuesta y quienes la la
contradicen la la digamos están en
contra de ella Esto está todavía en
discusión en la cámara de diputados y no
hay a la vista consensos posibles